hey man I'm Kevin Smith casey mears and
we play Jay and Silent Bob and that's
good because it's movie called James on
Bob reboot and it's coming out October
15 everywhere I think I'm gonna need to
see a blood test to Hollywood with you
know man
it's a tough fast neighborhood either
you take us to Hollywood or a stab you
both to death on my own [ __ ] phenol on
and on that note we cue the music I
don't think the world needed another
James Allen bob movie but we tried to
make clerks three and it didn't work
because one of the cast members didn't
one do it and then we tried to do
Mallrats too and that didn't work cuz
Universal didn't want to do it and so I
was frustrated and I was like you know
why don't we bang our heads against the
wall we own Jay & Silent Bob let's if I
want to play with my old toy so badly
why don't we do it with Jay and Samba at
least with reboot I put everything in it
I kind of capsulated my whole career and
my wife his family's in it his whole
family's in my whole family's in it and
stuff it's like a big scrapbook of a
movie but it is a gravestone of a movie
essentially look in the movie like your
lies Kevin Smith gives you everything
you need to know about who he was when
he was born when he died and all that
stuff in between it's a good stuff so
once we got the movie done then I was
like alright I feel better about life
now I could die but I'm still here he's
really clever in how he writes to bring
all the movies back like you know Jason
Lee you know reading off the the
computer just like Ben did in the last
one but different now instead of the
internet what's the Internet
what's a comic-con it's it's spoilers
it's good it's so it's super clever I
feel brew you we could have used that on
the poster super clever news exactly the
super clever the guy in the movie
Oh do I show them proposing Batman V
Superman well honestly I've watched this
movie 30 times now and I watch it every
time you know my wife's like why still
watching that movie because of Mike
because I'm gonna love it one day should
it have been made let's go to you I feel
like any movie with one cap for me be
careful the Internet is listening and
they're all sitting there waiting to
drag you because it's something that
I've always wanted to see not
necessarily that but I've always say hey
who could win in a fight the thing from
Fantastic Four of the Hulk or Superman
Batman Superman itself for me to get a
verb V in there I think I was happy it
was made you're late for that V your
whole life
yes I'm happy in every title man that's
it I'm happy they made a V maybe not
that movie but I'm happy they made a V
more V's for you Batman Batman
they are rebooting battle yes and the
boy from Twilight is gonna be Batman now
he's gonna Sparkle like a vampire in
Twilight now he's a genius actor this
kid Rob Pattinson he's gonna do great
jobs Batman and you should be happy he
they're not getting like some like
roided-out dude to play Batman they're
getting a little skinny kid like you so
that means you you could be next for
Batman yeah you don't need no muscles to
be Batman
why I don't know go back to Michael key
member Michael King did have no muscles
any athletes got lost
no what do you hold you you feel he'll
Wow Batman Matt Reeves Batman you on
board got Jonah Hill as either the
penguin or the Riddler we're not sure
maybe a combination of all the peddler
oh wow ring 1 no way but they are saying
it's one of those two rules I love it
I'm always down for new movies that
involves superheroes and/or crime
fighter co-sign do it Matt Reeves back
to the future I would no way I never
never in a million years Indiana Jones
never
discussion what kind of reboot are we
talking about
I'm talking about I don't I say no no no
yeah no way he's a good character and
yes but what who's your favorite a queue
like it's a for you
yes you love vintage I love what's this
that one of the crime shows you were
watching my Law & Order come on ten all
right and you love to miss King he's
made okay Steven Spielberg goes we're
doing Indiana Jones again in this time
it's Vincent D'Onofrio okay Jim do i
watch it sure well there you go
okay look how easily I flip ray we're
asking you can stick to your things make
a build knowledge care if it's Vincent's
but I don't think they should I don't
think they should do it I'm saying I
think they should add a vacation wait 10
years maybe after Harrison Ford is best
away which hopefully will be a hundred
years from now then they do it or they
yeah all right that makes that's a
character the we drew Bausman so that's
a character that they haven't like he's
an architect you'd get away of somebody
I think they should add it like Star
Wars almost again they did a charge and
then Shia LeBouf was and then people
like all right oh my gosh she's crazy
because y'all look really good and stuff
but yeah bad I'm swinging on trees in
the movies The Mummy the mummy is the
mummy better cuz Tom Cruise met the
mummy do I wasn't an okay world where
all the mummies had never met some
cruise yeah I think Wade made a bunch of
balloons I think they didn't need to
make that mummy because the old the old
ones were awesome but I thought on what
are the old ones to you the old ones are
what do you know what are they when you
said the old ones what mummies and these
are old there's three with brendan
fraiser here those are the old ones
you're talking about yes there's even
older ones than that bring it back so
even brendan fraiser you're about to
suck off and be like what a hero lea
they rebooted that movie so Ferran have
got to go way back so the question is
should anybody I've ever touched the
mummy after they did the mummy the first
two hot
yes Universal Monsters really because I
didn't know about the old money so for
me personally I needed the new mummy
with Brendan Fraser out of the mouths of
babes another vermin that's
exactly why reboots are okay because he
was never gonna watch the black and
white one movies even though we were in
one a lot of people know that name Tom
Cruise so it's like I think you know the
hot take right there Internet you hear
that a lot of people know the name Tom
Cruise yes
fight me okay yeah what was this a
catchphrase and go knock grew this yeah
Tom Cruise is good yeah
I'm rich madam I don't remember what
they need you it wasn't a him who jumped
on the couch and said something crazy
and he did but he didn't have a
catchphrase like snoots to the news
that's you but I was seeing it here so I
was taking notes to get a Charlie
Sheen's catchphrase which was winning
wait did you just literally confuse Tom
Cruise of the Charlie Sheen Charlie
Sheen feeling great Tom Cruise gone I
got a lot of work ahead of me still I
need a better publicist what yes Big
Trouble in Little China I don't know if
it's possible but I would like to see
how that turns out why the sacrilege to
remake this movie engineering movie uh
driven by personality man Claus I would
say can't remake movies where there's
key man evolved key man and this is John
Carpenter unless John Carpenter's reboot
in this movie I'm gonna you know I look
up I'll see it I see everything but I'm
mad about it that's for damn sure
just like I said I don't think it's
possible but I'd like to see what how it
turns out why not make it a repo right
where it's like I don't make it animated
movie chillin a repo you then you get
Kurt Russell in it he's back
and then you hand off the reins to
someone younger like Star Trek stuff get
JJ for this then then I'm their man but
other than that John Carpenter you need
John Carpenter he is Big Trouble in
Little China two key figures in that
movie John Carpenter Kurt Russell if you
ain't got either you got this
mmm Princess Bride no Andre the Giant
never I gotta tell you I'm shocked to
even knew the movie I'm shocked he
pulled Andre John I'm so proud of you
thanks so proud and you're absolutely
right without on wit look never even
without Andres no but somebody said to
me the other day cuz I was like no never
and they're like what if they did the
Dread Pirate Roberts movie where it's
just about like the many dudes who have
been the Dread Pirate Roberts and then I
was like you know so maybe there's a way
to do it don't reboot it you can't tell
The Princess Bride story again singular
moment in times like remaking clerks
don't do that much you call us and then
people that do you think they should do
it redo the boy are we doing boy it
wasn't without Wesley Snipes salary
doing well I don't know that it'll be
without maybe they'll find a way to work
a minute what if Wesley wants to be
involved but he won't be played by
Wesley estancia Mahalo
Polly oh yeah he's coming back his blade
he's gonna be way now they have rebooted
this the original series had a bunch of
sequels but then they rebooted it with
with another guy fairly recently and
they took all the humor enema yeah like
the first one was constituional and sell
for a dollar
the reboot was just like they're like
for reals man this cop is dead and now
he's a robot you know like it was very
very serious
would you agree boot Robocop no why
because I don't know what's the game
might you chuck you never lose count
much who didn't ask any of the pertinent
question oh say it three times
candy ran more time one more time Candy
Man [ __ ] mom they're redoing this I
have no skin in the candy man yeah what
does a sacrilege feels like if you
totally do this in a world where they
like did a thousand Halloween's and then
disavowed most of them feel like now the
new ones are good they could told my
Tony Todd Tony Todd did the first one
was that he was in it he didn't do it
but he was the guy thanking me and he
could totally come back or why another
role
or something like that I see a magic
Tony Todd is back you want but then it's
not reboot there's a Vinnitsa is it not
it's gonna be super even if everything
else is different
well can be a repo which is a sequel
with a reboot kind of right Star Trek
should they reboot Star Trek they have
our track JJ did it did a really great
job yes
yeah I like the new Star Trek the old
Star Trek I enjoy as well but a lot of
thinking a lot of sit around talking
that's kind of like clerks and stuff
JJ's Star Trek is like Ron's like
everybody's in a hurry and they have the
technology now
yeah they don't rebuild their space that
are stronger in space
well the first one with the space enjoy
but I'm saying now they can like
actually make things they looked at me
yeah what that is the final frontier so
it's nice you didn't believe it was on
TV you're like 13 space it's a TV show
what it does they can foil and stuff
like that now it's like full-on you know
do you run they're rolling over his
grave your music tinfoil crapping on an
American tin foil oh my god yeah
surprising now what let me tell you
something well here let's discuss it all
right let's do it
um I think I could go with this here's
why you know number one there was just
two kids yes there's a convenience store
they have turnover and employees all the
time and you get all sorts of quarks
beyond the camera number to bring a
little taste well and do none of the
work none of the work and if the movies
good
we'll get like credit even though we
didn't do anything oh yeah work smarter
not harder that's nice yeah Natalia my
kid got older and want to reboot the
movie that would be the best-case
scenario because then I could like
shadow director all sides and stuff cuz
I'm her dad I'm like oh no yeah
no that'd be awesome like that how sweet
I I hope to lure the Lord that my kid
gets the idea should sir plan that I do
yeah Evan be like you should reboot
closer watch this episode yeah what else
what we're doing
yeah yeah I'm like Amy you should watch
this thing on the internet she's get you
and your friend again and no wait dad
come on this might be nice today that
could be our thing man like the Smith
thing like how it's Philip Morris as
cigarettes we just have clerks for the
rest of like all time and steps and
people aren't why are we still watching
this because before guy yeah never um we
could be in them till we get little
cameos and stuff as old men to come in
the store a dog yeah you could come in
and be like hey where's the mall and the
audience would be like who else would
you wanted a clerks reboot playing Dante
would be right now I say did you ever
watch fleabag mm-hmm yeah wasn't it
Phoebe wallet bridge she's that that
fleabag is so good i watch it before the
end so don't accuse me of being a bad
way
no I was big-time I say let her play
both clerks all right and then I say
Thanos the guy who plays Thanos oh it
invents a guy who knows or Thanos
himself then no the guy who plays that
progesterone he is I really want to see
the version of clerks with Thanos who's
working that hey hey just because they
serve you doesn't mean that and every
weekend on that solutely the editor
[Music]
[Music]